in this video we're gonna look at trends
for the periodic table of elements for
dimensions like ionization energy atomic
and ionic radii electron affinity and
electronegativity and to do so we're
going to start with a very fundamental
idea in chemistry or physics and that's
Coulomb's law and for our point of view
we can view Coulomb's law as saying is
that the magnitude of the force between
two charged particles is going to be
proportional that just means
proportional right there is going to be
proportional to the charge on the first
particle times the charge on the second
particle divided by the distance between
those two particles squared when we're
thinking about it in context of the
periodic table of elements and various
atoms you can view q1 as the effective
positive charge from the protons in the
nucleus of an atom
you can view q2 as the charge of an
electron now any given electron has is
going to have the same negative charge
but as we try to understand trends in
the periodic table of elements it's
really the outermost shell electrons the
valence electrons that are most
interesting because those are the ones
that describe the reactivity and so when
we think about the distance between the
two charges were mainly going to be
thinking about the distance between the
nucleus and those outermost valence
electrons now we can view this effective
charge so I'll call it Z effective as
being equal to the difference between
the charge in the nucleus so you can
just view this as the atomic number
atomic number or the number of protons
that a given element or an atom of that
element has and the difference meaning
that and what is often known as s or how
much shielding there is now there is
complicated models for that but for an
introductory chemistry class this is
often approximated by the number of core
electrons remember we really want to
think about what's going on with the
valence electrons and so if you imagine
a nucleus here let me do that orange
color that has protons in it and so you
have core electrons
these are the core electrons in the
first shell and then you have some core
electrons in the second shell and let's
say the valence electrons are in the
third shell so let's say these are some
valence electrons here and they're
blurred around there in these orbitals
those valence electrons which have a
negative charge are going to be
attracted to the positive charge in the
nucleus but they're also going to be
repulsed by all these core electrons
that are in between them and so that's
why an approximation of the effective
charge that these valence electrons
might experience is going to be the
charge of the nucleus - and this is an
approximation the number of core
electrons that you have so if we use
that roughly as a way to think about Z
effective what do you think are going to
be the trends in the periodic table of
elements so I want to be the effective
charge for the Group 1 elements over
here well hydrogen has no core electrons
and it has atomic number of 1 so 1 - 0
it's going to have an effective charge
of roughly 1 lithium atomic number of 3
- two core electrons that are in 1s so
you're once again you're going to have 3
minus 2 effective charge of 1 so roughly
speaking all of these Group 1 elements
have an effective charge of 1 what if
you were to go to the halogens what are
the what's the effective charge there
well if you look at fluorine atomic
number of 9 has two core electrons in
the first shell so as an effective
charge of seven chlorine actually has an
effective charge of 7 for the same
reason atomic number of 17 but 10 core
electrons if you go even further to the
right to the noble gases you see that
helium is going to have an effective
charge of 2 atomic number of 2 minus and
0 core electrons but then when you get
to neon you have an atomic number of 10
and then - only two core electrons and
you'll see as you go down these noble
gases other than helium they have an
effective charge of 8 and so the general
trend is your effective charge is low at
the left effective charge low for group
1 and then when you go to the right of
the periodic table you have a Z
effective Z effective is going to be hot
so within a given period or within a
given row on the periodic table of
elements your outer electron
surveillance electrons are in the same
shell but the effective charge is
increasing as you go from left to right
so this q1 right over here is going to
be increasing so what is that going to
do to the radius of the atom
well Coulomb's law will say that the
magnitude of the attractive force
between those opposite charges is going
to be stronger and so even though you're
adding electrons as you go from left to
right within a row within a period the
atoms in general are actually going to
get smaller so let me write it this way
so as you go from left to right
generally speaking radius decreases now
what's the trend within a column well
one way to think about it is as you go
down a column as you go down a group
you're filling shells that are further
out and so you would expect radius to
increase as you go down a column or as
you go down a group or you could say
radius decreases as you go up a group so
radius decreases so overall what's the
trend in the periodic table of elements
well radius is going to decrease as you
go up and to the right and so you could
draw an arrow something like this and it
is indeed the case that by most measures
helium is considered to be the smallest
atom a neutral helium atom and francium
is considered to be the largest atom so
can we use this to think about other
trends in the periodic table of elements
what about for example ionization energy
just as a reminder the first ionization
energy is the minimum energy required to
remove that first electron from a
neutral version of that element and
since it's the minimum energy it's going
to be one of those outermost electrons
it's going to be one of the valence
electrons and so what's going to drive
that well you can imagine the ionization
energy is going to be high in cases
where the Coulomb forces are high and
what are the situations where the
Coulomb forces are high well this is
going to be a situation where you have a
high effective charge and where you have
a low radius lower
radius makes the Coulomb forces high an
effective charge makes the Coulomb
forces I so where is that true so you
have the lowest radiuses at the top
right and you have the highest effective
charge at the right so you would expect
the highest ionization energies to occur
in the top right so high high ionization
ionization energy and that actually
makes intuitive sense these noble gases
are very stable they don't want to
release an electron so it's gonna take a
lot of energy to take one of those
electrons away fluorine or chlorine
they're so close to completing a shell
the last thing they want to do is lose
an electron so once again it takes a lot
of energy to take that to take that
first electron away on the other hand if
you go to something like francium it has
one valence electron and that valence
electron is pretty far from the nucleus
and there is a low effective charge
despite all the protons because there's
so much shielding from all those core
electrons so it's not surprising that it
doesn't take a ton of energy to remove
that first electron from francium now
another trend that we can think about
which is in some ways the opposite is
electron affinity ionization energy is
talking about the energy it takes to
remove an electron electron affinity
thinks about how much energy is released
if we add an electron to a neutral
version of a given element so high
electron affinity elements these are the
ones that really want electrons so they
should have a high Coulomb force between
their nucleus and the outermost
electrons and so that means they should
have a high effective Z and that also
means that they should have a low R so
one way to think about it you're going
to have a similar trend with the one
difference that the noble gases don't
like gaining or losing electrons but we
do know that the fluorines are the
chlorines of the world can become more
stable if they gain an electron they can
actually release energy so you actually
have high electron affinities for the
top right especially the halogens and
you
low electron affinities at the bottom
left now there's one little quirk in
chemistry conventions people will
generally say that fluorine and chlorine
and the things in the top right that
aren't noble gases have a high electron
affinity and it is the case that energy
is released when you add an electron to
a neutral version of them it just
happens to be that the convention and
this can get a little confusing is that
when you release energy you have a
negative electron affinity but generally
speaking people are real when they say a
high electron affinity this is going to
release more energy when it's able to
grab an electron now a notion that is
related to electron affinity is
electronegativity and the difference
between the two can sometimes be a
little bit confusing electronegativity
is all about when an atom shares a pair
of electrons with another atom how
likely it is it to attract that pair to
itself versus for the pair to be
attracted away from it to the other one
and so you could imagine it correlates
very strongly with electron affinity
things that release energy when they are
able to be ionized to grab an electron
if they form a bond and they're sharing
a pair of electrons they are more likely
to hog those electrons electron affinity
is easier to measure you can actually
see when this elements in a gaseous
state if you add electron how much
energy is released it's normally
measured in kilojoules per mole of the
atom in question while electronegativity
isn't as clear-cut on how to measure it
but it can be a useful concept in future
videos as we think about different atoms
sharing pairs of electrons and where do
the electrons spend most of their time
so I'll leave you there
we started with Coulomb forces and we
were able to intuit a whole bunch of
trends just thinking about the Coulomb's
law and the periodic table of elements